Okay, so just to be completely clear, Dr.
Stenning, we just need the baby out
somewhere in this window.
But preferably not 3 to 4 days of this date.
Right.
And why is that?
Because we have a lot of busy social
occasions to attend.
So when could you induce?
Only if you're overdue.
Or if or if there are, there are problems.
Have you any conditions?
Well defined conditions.
Diabetes?
No.
High blood pressure. No kidney problems?
Well, there's no foreseeable reasons, I'm
afraid. Oh, f***.
F***.
Oh, well, what if I were to have some kind of
accident? I mean, non-fatal.
Like, what if someone were to break my arm?
Dr. Stenning, what is the earliest that we
could book a C-section?
36 weeks.
Wow.
So we're doing that.
We're doing that.
What is the recovery process.
From cesarean?
Anything up to about six weeks.
Yeah.
And what does that involve?
Well, mainly rest, recovery from the
stitches. Stitches.
No, no, that won't work.
Well, the healing is much longer than for a.
No. If I go to one of our social occasions
and I have stitches, I'll bust open.
Just in a matter of speaking.
Mary, do you mind if I ask what it is that
you're scared of?
Well, I'm just.
I don't want our baby to get hurt.
Well, let's start by booking you in for the
ultrasound.
Who's going to be at the ultrasound.
Just the sonographer.
But if you're nervous, I can arrange to be
there.
No, you don't know.
It's. Don't put yourself out.
Mary. It's very important that you don't let
your anxiety take control.
Now, normally, I'd be seeing patients a lot
sooner than I'm seeing you guys, but there
are some classes that can help you get up to
speed and settle some of these nerves.
In through the nose for three.
Out through the nose for three.
Slow it down.
Relax the shoulders.
Relax the face.
The jaw. Keep it floppy.
Floppy in the nose for three.
Out for three.
Great. Scaredy cat, out.
Happy cow!
Oh, look at these happy cows.
So happy.
Yes, all that oxytocin.
And back up again.
Arching that back.
Scaredy cat.
What hormone relates to birth and sex?
Yes.
Oxytocin it does.
What organ contracts
with.
oxytocin? Mary.
Um.
I don't know. Sorry.
And. This look right to you babe?
Hey, what's the matter?
We're just going through the motions.
Look, I
think that this is an important.
None of it applies to us.
There aren't companies making soft, plushy
wolf uteruses. You don't know that.
I do know that there aren't companies making
those. No, I mean
you don't know that. None of that applies to
us. Okay? We could be having a baby.
Yeah, we
could be having a wolf. I don't know how to
mother, a wolf, Gary, and neither do you.
Then let's get the ultrasound.
Okay? We just need to know exactly what is
going on in there. Then we can start
worrying about everything else.
For example, did you know that it's possible
for a wolf to give birth to up to ten pups?
Why would you tell me that?
Mary. Hey, Anna.
The girls and I are going to that organic
cafe around the corner. If you wanted to
join us. Yes.
Absolutely.
That would be great. What a great idea.
I'll Uber home. Take the car.
Go have fun.
Take as long as you need.
I'll be open with each other and just.
Really express our feelings and what's going
on. It's really fantastic.
Oh I can't, let's go have a beer.
Yeah, yeah. I mean, it's so good having
other dads to talk to, isn't it?
Imagine not having anyone.